it was a dark moment in British politics
Joe Cox an opposition Labour MP was
fatally shot and stabbed outside her
constituency office
she'd campaigned to remain in the EU the
killer had shouted keep Britain
independent as he carried out the attack
police have warned people not to inflame
tensions caused by brexit but politics
has rarely been so toxic especially for
women
Caroline Spellman was an MP for 22 years
her stance on brexit led to months of
rape and death threats she carries a
panic button and her children's bedrooms
have steel doors I asked my male
colleagues whether they'll also get
threats of a sexual nature
you know threats to rape or being
referred to by their genitalia I mean
they're horrified why is it then in our
culture that this has been allowed to
happen Spelman is one of a slew of
prominent female MP standing down at the
next election including the former Home
Secretary and Brad all because of abuse
and intimidation this of course is where
many politicians begin their careers
knocking on doors meeting supporters and
of course opponents we'd rarely find a
single politician that would do this
alone these days many citing fear of
violence and abuse despite the risks
Olga Fitzroy's campaigning to become an
MP in South London she blames an old
boys network of MPs that includes the
prime minister of fueling misogyny Boris
Johnson has been really irresponsible in
his language
you know he's cold Muslim women
letterboxes and he just keeps coming out
with things like that and because he's a
privileged white man who's very well
protected he doesn't face any of the
issues that some of the female
politicians and female politicians of
color face politics is now full of
divisive terms traitor
betrayal surrender words used in death
threats to female MPs words also
regularly used by the Prime Minister
when asked to modify his language this
is how Johnson responded
I have to say mr. speaker I've never
heard such humbug in all my life
but Johnson can't afford to be
complacent the female vote matters
household names well known to two female
voters they will be exiting stage left
I think female voters will notice that
and and they will take it seriously in
terms of how they determine their vote
earlier this year the MP and a Sabri was
confronted by a mob outside Parliament
in led to several arrests despite calls
for calm research by Cardiff and
Edinburgh universities found that most
leave and remain voters now think
violence towards MPs is a price worth
paying for brexit the findings shocked
the researchers weeks away from the
election the relationship between
politicians and people has never looked
so troubled Nev Barca al Jazeera London